last night's cacophonous and chaotic
Republican presidential primary debate
ended with one of the wildest questions
ever posed in any presidential debate
none of you have indicated that you're
dropping out so which one of you on
stage tonight should be voted off the
island
please use your marker to write your
choice on the notepad in front of you 15
seconds starting out of the people on
the stage who should be I'm absolutely
serious with all due respect I mean
we're here like we're happy to debate on
that I think that that's disrespectful
to my fellow competitors
do some questions let's talk about the
future of the country it's a good answer
from DeSantis that was the smart way to
play it what's funny is Christy then
went along and he said yeah we don't
want to participate but he was the first
one when she said it he just starts
writing down on his board but okay then
they said no we don't want to
participate at all it's a terrible
terrible question